Composition of a great arm wrestler.
What makes one great in the sport?
So I will discuss in this video all the factors that can influence your performance on the table.
Why is it important?
You can judge your physique or the state you're in at the moment and think, "Am I checking those boxes?" And you can also adapt your training to get
everything, like the whole package that is needed to win the match. We used to think, or like to think, that it's all about strength, and I think that's the biggest mistake we have, because peak strength is obviously important, but I don't think it's the most important thing for arm wrestling. So I have created a small list of categories that are important for an arm wrestler, and I
divide that into two main categories: trainable and not trainable, because there are some natural things you have in your body, in your frame, in your recovery rates, and things like that that you can't train, and they give you an obvious advantage in the sport. But we'll start with those you can train, not to spoil your humor, okay?
So the first thing in the trainable category is something I call motion, okay?
So it relates to everything that allows you to move.
So basically, it's about the tendon-muscle unit.
Muscle size is pretty obvious.
The bigger the muscle is, the stronger the muscle is.
It's been proven by many, many studies.
We see it in many sports.
So if you want to have,
if you want to be strong, just get your muscles big.
This is why we also train for hypertrophy.
And I don't think it has to be explained further.
Another thing is tendon stiffness, which is pretty important.
And now, as we start to talk about isometrics, we start to recognize the importance of this thing, too.
Actually, tendon stiffness is important for the transmission of force.
So if your muscle is huge but the
tendon is not stiff, you will not be able to generate the same amount of force in a given time, which is crucial for an arm wrestling match. So tendon stiffness is second, aside from the size of the muscle, that is insanely important. And if you, for some reason, have super-stiff tendons, well, maybe you can compensate for the muscle
when you are lacking muscle size, and vice versa, but it's good to have it balanced.
In the trainable category, we also have the subcategory of the nervous system.
So strength is a skill.
And we all know that just having big muscles doesn't help you to be stronger.
This is like the difference between bodybuilders and powerlifters.
Powerlifters are stronger,
but they are not that big because the size of the muscles is not the only component.
So you need to teach your body, you need to teach your nervous system, actually, to fire all accessible muscle fibers at the same time to produce force.
And this is called rate of force development.
I mean, not directly, but it comes from rate of force development.
So rate of force development, for those who don't know,
is a measurement that allows you to check how fast you can produce force.
Which is super important in arm wrestling.
Probably more important than maximum strength.
And you can train it.
That's a good thing.
But you need to train it in a specific way.
Another thing that you can train your nervous system to do is
the move, the technique you're using.
So the more proficient you become at arm wrestling moves, the better you get at arm wrestling, and that's also a nervous system adaptation.
So we can already see, just from these two categories, that your training should stimulate not only muscle growth and tendon stiffness,
but also, you need to learn how to arm wrestle properly. You also need to focus on how to get faster and how to get your contractions faster, because some people might say, like, "Okay, but speed is not important because speed is understood in the wrong way." Speed is not how fast you go for a flash pin, okay? The speed is how
many milliseconds you need to get from zero to one hundred percent of your strength.
Or how much power you can generate, for example, at two hundred milliseconds.
This is very important.
Because the speed that allows you to travel from a starting position to the pin pad is also technique.
So if you move your body properly, if you teach your body how to do it,
you become faster, but it doesn't necessarily mean that your muscle contraction gets faster.
So you need to focus on those two things separately or simultaneously, depending on your training, but you need to do it.
The third category of trainable factors is actually your head.
It's very, very important in the sport.
So the first thing is you have to be patient.
Patience is really
I think, yeah, I don't know if there's anything more important in arm wrestling than patience.
Just give it time because you won't jump into the sport and be super good, like in other disciplines.
You will have some advantages at the beginning, but it takes time to develop.
Because of how our hands and forearms are built, because of how small the muscles are, a lot of factors, actually, but patience and...
This is what some people say: you need to fall in love with training, with progress, with the process.
But actually, you need to be patient.
If you are here for very fast gains, it may disappoint you.
So, patience.
And the second thing is discipline.
You need to be disciplined because going from time to time, doing, you know, short bursts of exercises, I train...
weeks to the maximum and then I take one week off or something like that, that's not gonna bring you anywhere high. You can be genetically gifted and you can still smash everyone in your club if you're coming just for sparring sessions, but it won't work if you want to think about arm wrestling in a professional way or if you want to reach a higher level. So these are the things that you actually
work on, because you can work on your patience, you can work on your discipline.
There are training methods I will be discussing, especially the rate of force development, because I think there are not enough sources online about this.
You can work on all of this.
So right now you can already think about how many of these things in your training you are skipping.
And instantly, if you're going to implement them in your training, after some time,
be patient, a few months at least, you will see the improvement.
And now we're coming to the non-trainable things, and that might upset some people because some people believe that you can do everything and there is no such thing as being predisposed to sports of any kind, but actually, in arm wrestling, it's very visible.
I think it's in every sport, actually.
But in arm wrestling, we just can't see it.
So let's start with frame.
The bigger the frame is, the higher your potential in arm wrestling is.
If you have a wrist like that, like something like that, which is a really average wrist.
I've checked, and my wrist is, sadly, average for the whole world.
I'm like one millimeter thicker than the average male wrist on the planet.
which obviously is a huge problem in arm wrestling because the average arm wrestler is way thicker than the average person, and especially I'm European, and we are bigger and thicker than people on the other continents. So, yeah, me being average, I have literally the smallest wrists in the club, the sparring place I usually go to every Sunday, so
being average is not what benefits you. You would rather be super thick with your bone structure and everything. It helps, and this is a general rule for strength sports. And in this frame category, there are freaky things. So there are guys that are freaky
And sometimes, at first look, you don't think, "Oh, John Brzenk is just a regular guy."
But then you see his thumb, and he is a freak.
It's so huge, so massive, that it actually starts to make sense why he reached this level.
Devon Larratt, I don't know how it's even possible, but his thumb is like... it's like that.
It's insanely big, insanely big.
Look at Matt Mask's hands.
These fingers are from another planet, you know.
I don't even want to talk about people like Oleh Zhokh, right?
But even Makarov.
Look at how wide Makarov's hand is.
It's like you could place three fingers here.
And the fingers would go straight.
So these guys, or even Coach Ray, right?
Someone who is not considered to be the best arm wrestler in the weight class,
but take a look at the length of his forearm.
It's unusual for his size, for his height.
His forearms are super long.
And you can find, maybe not in every one of these guys, but you will find something that gives them natural advantages.
So, for example, Bacho Saginashvili: the thumb is placed a little bit differently, higher.
How thick he is.
Like, the first time I saw this guy, I wasn't shocked by the hand size or something like that.
I was shocked by how huge his frame is.
The amount of muscle he can put on his body makes him what he is, because he's wider than anyone.
And yeah, that's why he's champion.
So you will find these special things, like, for example,
the width of the hand, the length of the fingers, the size of the thumb, how long this bone is, right?
What else?
Yeah, there are many, actually, that can be beneficial for arm wrestling, but these are the main ones that are noticeable straight away.
Even the way your biceps is attached.
Right, because, for example, Yoshinobu Kanai, of course, it wasn't his frame from the beginning of his life. He had surgery, but he was modified, so now his frame is different because his biceps attaches in a different place, and we have a guy who is hard to beat even though he's not the strongest, right?
So those freakish, freakish things are pretty, pretty important.
And yeah, another thing from another category, from the non-trainable, is genetics.
So, for example, the composition of your muscles.
Are you slow-twitch- or fast-twitch-dominant?
And if you're slow-twitch-dominant, I have bad news for you.
That's not favoring you.
For me, obviously, I am slow-twitch-dominant.
So I have greater endurance than pretty much everyone, but at the same time, it's really hard to be as fast as the other guys.
So I'm most of the time on the B-side, right?
Even if I control the match completely, I start on the B-side.
Obviously, it's nice to have some endurance. You can train some endurance, but definitely you want to be fast-twitch for this sport because you get an advantage right off the go.
Tendon length.
This is something you can't change.
And it's also maybe not very important, but also a factor that you are born with.
So the shorter the tendon is, the bigger the advantage you will have at the beginning, at the hit.
So if you
feel good when starting completely loose and then, boom, hitting, maybe you have super tendons. Maybe you are fiber-type-two dominant, but maybe also your tendons are short. And actually, I need to investigate this a little bit further, but if you see super-good guys who don't have muscles
It doesn't mean that they don't have muscles, but they don't have muscles in the bodybuilding sense.
So their biceps are not super pointy or something like that.
But how do you get these super-pointy biceps?
By having a longer tendon.
So it may be that they are flatter, but I need to find more studies to prove it.
It's just my theory.
I just want to underline that.
That's my observation, and I didn't put in enough work to be able to say one hundred percent that this is true.
I think if your muscles are a bit flatter, they don't have these significant bumps, let's say, it may mean that you have shortened tendons, which benefit you at the go, and you are faster because of this.
And there is another genetic factor that is super important, super important:
how you react to performance-enhancing drugs.
So this is something that obviously not everyone is taking.
But unfortunately, in arm wrestling right now, if you want to be very competitive at higher weight classes, if your body
responds well to anabolics, you are probably gonna make a better career. They say even in bodybuilding, you don't know your potential until the first cycle, till the first cycle. Unfortunately, this is what it is.
So if you can't handle
different PEDs, you will have side effects you can't handle, you know.
Well, that may be a bad option for you, and you should stick to lower weight categories.
But if you can put a bar of plutonium in your mouth and swallow it, and you're gonna be fine.
Maybe you can go super heavy.
So these are the things that I think that are
I don't know if they're equally important, but their importance is significant, and I think to be the world champion, you need to check all these boxes. There is some room, obviously, for differences, because, for example, okay, you are slow, so you can load as much as you can at the go, and then
you can be more efficient at the start. You can cheat it somehow, okay? So you can be perfectly... you know, your nervous system can be trained and prepared to the max. You can do nervous system priming before the fight. You can have all these methods of getting the maximum from the fight, and it
covers some other lacks, but the other guy can do that too.
So even if you are better and more professional, I would say, you can mask your disadvantages with it.
But if the guy who has advantages is at the same level of professionalism as you, that's it, you're doomed.
So yeah, this is what it is, in my opinion.
Take it into consideration. Set your goals realistically.
If you have hands like that, it might be a bad idea to go one hundred five, for example.
This is what I mean.
And maybe then you don't even have to know if your body reacts well to performance enhancement, because you still have those short fingers, right?
And if, from the trainable
things that I've mentioned, you are not covering them all in training, that's an easy way to get better.
So anyway, that's it for now.
Bye.